foreign
thank you good morning and welcome to
the subcommittee uh work session on
Senate bill 240.
um with this I would like to recognize
representative Weber she has a couple
amendments that she'd like to speak to
thank you madam chair
um
when we got this bill
it I was very confused about what we
were trying to do and we were trying to
do it all in one
condensed sentence or a couple of
sentences
and so I talked extensively to folks
from Dartmouth medical I talked
extensively to Senator Prentice I talked
to several other people and it occurred
to me rightly or wrongly that we have
two different things going on here on
the one hand Senator Prentice brought
the bill originally because she was very
concerned because a constituent of hers
had been told that she could not consent
to having her own DNA used in ways that
might be very beneficial to her for her
treatment and she was told that that was
not allowed
and I went to law school a long time ago
and I know things have changed but that
kind of made the back of my head blow
off so
um
many people have said that isn't the way
it is but clearly there is some kind of
a problem there and if if if we are in
fact and we haven't discussed it yet all
agreed that people should have the right
to consent I think it's very important
that we make it more clear in the
statutes that that's the way it is so
that was item number one and that was
the easy bet and then the second bit was
the use of genetic material for
um
research purposes which is very
beneficial to everybody but again the
issues of privacy the issues of
ownership over your own DNA is of
Paramount concern to all of us so what
I'm going to pass out are two amendments
the first one which is 1718 simply adds
in a sentence saying uh that the section
will not prohibit the disclosure with
the written consent of the patient of
genetic testing or genetic analysis to
entities participating in processes
related to either clinical care of the
patient including but not limited to
evaluating potential options or to
clinical research so that's item number
one I'm going to start by passing that
one out
just
here and I'm being stingy with the
copies because I need to have copies of
these that are committee thanks to the
committee
in case we get to the point of time
should be healed
I'll make the inside rotten seconds
the second one attempts
[Music]
to
um
yeah separate out
personal care and research so it's
a formulation that came from Dartmouth
Medical
thank you
just do this to have a few steps in for
the day
so with that
um
I think the only thing that bears a
certain amount of looking at is uh the
second one which is 2023 1719
and as you can see
it has
the provision about genetic testing and
genetic analysis to clinical entities or
HIPAA business associates
uh related to clinical care of the
patients
and then the second part is specific
informed consent for clinical research
and it doesn't prohibit the disclosure
of de-identified data
or limited minimum necessary data within
a covered entity that constitutes
genetic testing or genetic analysis in
the context of an IRB approved
retrospective clinical study and I think
that the stumbling Point here
may be that if you're doing a study
uh
indicators like how old the patient was
and other things like the patient's
lifestyle and other things are actually
very relevant to the study
um
and so how de-identified things get is
an issue going forward so with that I
have set the groundwork and I will
turn it back to the chair thank you very
much I believe representative Merchant
also has some amending language I think
if we can get this all out in front of
us it gives us a better point to start
the discussion
so if you'd like to distribute those and
then speak to those after you do thank
you
no I'll take it thank you
Madam chair can I speak to my Amendment
yes please do thank you
so
I'm trying to
retain
the intent of what's here at the same
time to protect the patient
um where I'm coming from is that when I
was on the Board of Pharmacy there was
an issue that was brought to our
attention where a patient went into a
pharmacy to get naloxone
for somebody it wasn't themselves but
they were using their prescription plan
to pay for it
that's before we had actually had a lot
of the locks on it off the board now for
about four or five years
what happened subsequent to that
was the patient got a letter from his
insurance carrier
dealing with the fact that they
considered him to be an addict because
he wouldn't get naloxone the question
was where does it flow because it goes
back to HIPAA business associates
because under the business
Associates HIPAA does allow for
insurance companies to get information
because you need it for billing
and that's where a lot of it came from
so I'm okay with having the information
shared amongst clinicians for the
clinical care of the patient but I'm not
comfortable with having the information
going to a HIPAA business associate
because it's very Broad
so that's kind of the intent of this one
here was to narrow it down and saying it
only can be shared amongst clinicians
for the clinical analysis or involvement
with the patient care
I did retain the part about the
identified information I think from a
research point of view if you go to the
IRB board you need to have information
to help drive that decision based upon
information that's factual but it
doesn't disclose the patient because
it's been de-identified so that's kind
of where I'm coming from in this
amendment
definitely appreciate that one of the
concerns that I have is around the
potential scope of The Limited minimum
necessary data and I I like the
amendment that you have representative
Merchant but I would I'd personally like
to see on a specific required consent of
any patient whose genetic data would be
used in a research trial perhaps letting
them know what the what the protocol was
and what it was being used for and how
they could contribute to that evolving
science on their disease State because
I'm not a fan of blank checks and I
think that that would be a good balance
to me that seems that may be a good
balance between what we see and being
able to consent if you want to and then
understand what you're consenting to
with that limited minimum necessary data
representative Weber
I'm wondering if it would be helpful or
useful
for us to consider the two questions
separately and start with the question
about what the consent patient can send
to in the context of their own treatment
and
um
I'm
willing to go along with representative
Merchant's formulation
and I don't know whether you are going
to recognize audience members or not but
I know there are people here who would
probably like to speak more probably
both to the clinical aspects of the
patient care and the clinical aspects of
the research
so that but that's up to you yes um
thank you I will be recognizing people
to speak I wanted to sort of figure out
where we were as a subcommittee so that
then that could guide the feedback that
we're but I would love to take up that
first piece because I think it's more
likely that we will be able to achieve
some kind of consensus on the first
piece because there are very few moving
Parts there and then go on
to the more difficult piece whether it's
if we can come to a conclusion that's
fine but I I really want to be sure not
been given the opportunity to consent
and in this case it was specifically and
this is where I think somebody with
clinical knowledge will be helpful to us
uh because while I agree entirely with
everything representative Merchant said
uh my understanding is that there is
some difference between
um
the clinical care that is given by the
various departments in a hospital and
even Consultants outside a particular
field and submitting the
genetic material to people who are
conducting studies and making sure that
we are clear that with their consent
they can consent to having their DNA
sent so that they can be reviewed for
appropriateness of a particular trial
um and how we get there is
my guess is we're probably all agreed on
that but I think it does make sense to
take up one section of the next
representative merchants and thank you
madam chair I do concur with what trips
the Weber is saying break into two parts
um
I do like the idea and Amendment
17 18 where president Weber talks about
written consent of the patient I'd like
to
further expand upon that because
many times when I've gone into a clinic
or
institution if you will
and I signed tons of documents and
basically at that point in time I don't
really don't want this buried somewhere
within 20 pages of documentation that it
really has to be specific and really
point out to the patient that what
they're consenting to and not have it
somewhere buried into a large consent
form because of the gravity of the
situation but again the information is
very sensitive
and be sure the patient does understand
fully what they're consenting to so we
could have some sort of documentation to
a clue that we're being very specific
about it I think good point reps of
Weber makes a lot of sense I'd like to
add to it and expand upon it
um I agree with that statement I do
believe that we should have more written
more clarity around that written consent
and i would support an effort to do that
with that should is would we be ready to
recognize audience members to speak
towards um so we will be ready to
towards the clinical care of the patient
and around the written consent of the
patient
but would you like to just
I guess if you raise your hand oh sorry
if you have a better idea and I I think
you need to go to the table and sit
because I suspect I I don't know whether
subcommittees are broadcast but in in
the event that they are it would be nice
that people could hear your voices even
if they can't see your faces
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
Matthew Hood I'm the vice president of
government relations with Dartmouth
health and with me is Dr Todd Morrell
um a clinician at Dartmouth Health uh
happy to speak to the Amendments that
have been proposed if that is the
pleasure of the committee uh and
understand the desire to separate happy
to do that as well
yes thank you if we can speak to that
first section first that would be
wonderful
okay
um so
if I may just by getting a little bit of
background to this issue because I
realized there was some confusion with
respect to what we were trying to do
um and to reiterate a couple points
the law of New Hampshire requires
consent to even take a DNA sample so we
already we get consent in compliance
with uh existing law
the the law actually precludes telling
anybody that a test was conducted with
certain exceptions one of the exceptions
is when you send the the material to a
lab to have it tested an exception to
what exception to a specific consent
requirement because of course
wouldn't be very helpful to have a
sample taken if you couldn't do analysis
on that by a lab
what the intent was to do
was to say
does it make sense to get consent from
someone a patient who's consented to
testing who to whoms the materials were
sent to a lab for analysis if what
you're doing is finding the best
treatment protocol available for that
patient I'm going to defer to Dr Burrell
to elaborate on this but we have we have
very little issue with the amendment
that was proposed by representative
Merchant
um
with the change of two words from only
allows to shall not prohibit and the
reason for that is because it only
allows would refer to the clinical lab
presumably in the previous sentence that
that's
um more narrow than the initial intent
of the bill was was drafted so when we
pause catch my breath uh see if Dr moral
has additions clarifications he'd like
to make on that topic
thank you
um
I again I for for my purposes in that
first section
uh as this amendment written it really
accomplishes that that we have clinical
Partners who help provide some systems
to take care of the patients
enlarge the vast majority of those
systems have no interest in anyone's
genetic data they don't
see it touch it use it or anything like
that but in rare instances particularly
around cancer treatment and around
children with genetic diseases
um those systems may be necessary in
order to help them get to the best
possible care
so all for as a clinician all that I'm
really hoping for is that we can include
those Partners the way that we do it
include them in any other care that
we're doing for patient for patients
that we could include the information
necessary
so that patients would have the
opportunity to hear about the treatments
available to them so they had the
opportunity to consent to that treatment
or decline that treatment
but that we may need that information
shared with in our
clinical systems in order to present
patients with their their best options
so I I think this as it's written
um
being able to share that analysis with
clinical entities participating in the
clinical care of the patient would would
certainly suit my needs to be able to
include those partners
and I'm not looking to talk to insurance
companies or disclosed to business
partners or anything like that I'm just
talking about clinical partners for for
my purposes okay
representative Merchant thank you
in regards to the words you'd like to
change or recommend to be changed
could you say those again
just do it uh so I'm thank you for the
question uh I'm looking at your
Amendment 1736 the first line of the new
proposed says this section only allows
I'm suggesting changing only allows to
shall not prohibit
yeah Emperor clarification why does that
change make a difference because I read
the additional sentence of this section
only allows to refer back to a clinical
lab we're not talking about a clinical
lab we're talking about other clinical
partners that might do matching for
patients thank you
shall not prohibit because
the sentence may need to be different
and may need to be redrafted but when
you say shall not prohibit you're
broadening broadening broadening
broadening broadening and my intent and
the reason that I phrased
my section the way I did is to make sure
that we are focused once again on the
written consent of the patient
to use for the patient's care so that's
what I put into
Amendment 17 18h
I am happy to have it in the different
section I'm happy to have this language
um
revised
but when we get to the shall not
prohibit you are broadening the
permissions you are not limiting the
permissions so if we need to make it
clear that we're not talking about
limiting what you do with your own lab
then we need to say that
um I think that
um I I guess as an attorney I have more
faith in informed consent and I probably
shouldn't but I also believe that the
people who are concerned about consent
read those forms and the people who
aren't concerned don't and that's their
choice so
um you know there's a certain amount of
how far do we go about protecting people
from themselves
so that's my concern with the shell nut
prohibit language I'm not wedded to my
own language I just
would prefer
something that makes it clear that this
is the patient's decision and that the
patient has to do something clear to
direct it
uh rather than just saying oh you can
use it for all of these other things
because it sounds like you don't have to
make that as clear in a consent form and
what I'm really pleading for is clear
consent forms
thank you representative Merchant and
welcome
president Weber
the issue of the lab I always thought
the lab was a clinical lab so it's part
of taking care of the patient because
you're providing clinical care you're
not it's not direct care but it's in
direct care to the patient because
without the information coming from the
clinical lab it's difficult for any
provider clinician to do the work
without that information
some kind of lost there
yes representative Weber I wonder if we
took
representative Merchants section and on
line eight
simply remove the word clinical as it
relates to clinical entities and say
entities
I know I'm suggesting striking that out
and saying analysis to entities
participating in clinical care of the
patient so
any entity that is related to the care
of the patient doesn't have to be a
necessarily clinical
entity and I don't know if that gets us
any farther forward
we yes we're amenable to other language
choices with respect to also includes
representative Weber as opposed to shall
not prohibit I mean whatever
articulation of that you think makes
sense to
representative Merchant's question and I
thank it for the question because we're
trying to get the clarity that what what
how the importance of the role of a
clinical lab you've identified but
they're also a crucial role of other
entities that are facilitating the care
of patients that aren't enumerated in
this statute that we'd like that's we're
trying to see Clarity to enumerate those
is taking the word on line eight of the
amendment I proposed in Striking
clinical achieve that
and leaving the sentence as he
originally wrote it
I'm saying only allows as opposed to
shall not prohibit
foreign
yes I think it does uh I could stop
there but I will say or I could confuse
this further which is to say you could
also amend the first line that gives
permission to let clinical labs and say
other entities because that clearly
references the clinical care that's
provided I defer to you with respect to
the drug what line are you speaking of
um so Roman 4 starts nothing in the
section shall be construed to regulate
or apply to genetic testing or genetic
analysis for diagnosis and treatment of
a patient by a Clinical Laboratory you
could also add in or other entity in
there I'm again I defer totally to the
subcommittee with respect to whether
you'd like a second sentence or just
elaborate the type of entities to whom
disclosure can be made
with that language what are you
suggesting or the tree line five genetic
analysis used for diagnosis and
treatment of a patient by a Clinical
Laboratory or other entity participating
in clinical care of the patient that has
received a specimen referral I I
appreciate that question I think it also
might point out the fault of my
recommendation because that's specific
to the receipt of the specimen and only
a lab is receiving the specimen that
another entity might be receiving the
results of it so as we talk this through
thank you madam chair and representative
Mike frankly require two sentences as
opposed to one
I have another question subcommittee and
for both of you gentlemen looking to the
language of this at The Meta language on
seven
um I'm just going to go with the Shawna
prohibit just to put this out here this
section shall not prohibit the
disclosure with the written consent of
the patient of genetic testing or
genetic analysis to entities
participating in clinical care of the
patient I'm trying to pull together
these different equipments
I like that
again what
we're trying to thread here is that that
consent is not buried somewhere else so
how do we somehow identify that the
patient really is getting written
consent specific to this
and not have it and
20 pages of documentation they sign when
they come in
how about saying with the specific
written consent of the patient
that would work yes
so are are we now then down to just
whether we're going to say only allows
or shall not prohibit
I think that's the large remaining
question in my mind and I'm not a lawyer
the representative Merchant I'm going to
default to the attorney on the panel
oh crumbs
um
I'm just trying to read it in the
context of what came before but
in the section shall be considered to
regularly reply to genetic testing or
analysis used for diagnosis and
treatment of a patient
Clinical Laboratory that has received a
specimen okay so that's the very
specific language in the first sentence
foreign
I think that for me
um
I mean the first thing is about what is
not regulated and the second sentence is
um
I do think we've got more stuff going on
there because there is the issue of
everything that it relates back to
and
I wonder if instead of saying only
allows
we say specifically that the section
allows the disclosure
with the written cons specific written
consent of the patient
and take out the word only
so it would read this section allows the
disclosure with the specific written
consent of the patient
of genetic testing or genetic analysis
to entities participating in the
clinical care of the patient
would that work
I don't think we're aligned on this and
I'm going to try to back up and
articulate why
once again this section to to your point
uh representative whoever is the point
that provides an exception to
the prohibition of sharing data the
exception to that prohibition is for
sharing with the clinical lab to run the
test
what we are saying is that we think
there should also be an exception to the
specific prohibition of sharing for
utilization of other clinical partners
that can actually help identify
treatment treatment plans is that fair
correct okay so
um uh
the adding back of specific consent is
counter intuitive and where we're trying
to have this additional exception placed
your microphone is off not
representative Weber
my apologies I'm going back to the
actual section and I wonder
if maybe what we need to do is find an
earlier home
for the specific language
not in the exception section which is
you say is clunky
and
so what
H2 starts with as section one is except
as otherwise provided in this chapter no
individual or member of the family shall
be required to undergo genetic testing
as a condition of doing business with
any other person
section two is accept is required to
establish paternity or test newborns for
metabolic disorders or criminal
investigation or prosecution
or the medical examiner no genetic
testing should be done on it
any individual or anywhere on any
Resident in the state based on bodily
materials obtained within the state
without prior written and informed
consent of the individual to be tested
parent Guardian a custodian of the
individual or the legal guardian or
conservator of the issue or the legal
guardian or conservative if the
individual is incompetent
no person shall refuse to perform
genetic testing or arrange for genetic
testing to be performed or to do
business with the individuals solely
because they refuse to be contest tested
so I wonder if perhaps
uh and then section three is the
non-disclosure which says except as in
paragraph two no person shall disclose
to any other person that an individual
has undergone the testing
and uh consent consent consent
um
and I wonder if perhaps between section
2 and section 3 or between Section 3 and
section four is where the specific
language that we are talking about
should reside
rather than in the middle of a section
that's talking about exceptions
and I I would actually like to take that
a little further and zoom out or I
assume that you are not in the whole
section 141h but in the section 141 H
colon two I'm in 141 H colon 2 which is
where we are considering answer adding
this as part of section Roman four but
it seems to me that Romans 2 and 3 are
more related to this
and therefore might be a better place to
put it um as we zoom out to
um three four and five
um H colon 3 is use of genetic testing
and employment situations H colon 4 is
use of genetic testing and health
insurance and H colon 5 is use of
genetic testing and life disability
income and long-term care insurance
since we're looking at the use of
genetic testing in clinical care that
may actually stand better as its own
section so that we can discuss these
different nuances in these different
sections I'm not sure if I'm reaching
too far or if that might actually be
more appropriate way to draft this I
don't know if you have input from the
members of the committee or if I would
have no problem inserting between
141 H colon 2 and 141h colon 3 something
that says use of genetic testing
in clinical
for for clinical treatment
and then just putting this section in
and and then
so I think that that one's that one
sentence I I think that's absolutely a
good start I think we may want to look
at some of the uses and the way that
this actually would be done because
we're looking at making sure that
essentially we're able to use biomarkers
for treatment and research
um and I think we probably want to flesh
this out more to understand the uses
um so I I do know that uh down at Dana
Farber they actually pay for the genetic
testing and as part of the consent they
consent for all that matching and all of
that research use
um so I'm actually hoping doctor that
you can inform us a little bit more
about how you use this what your
limitations are and what you'd like to
see ideally sure so
in order to to get into a clinical trial
for cancer patients right many many of
those right there are clinical trials
being run all over the country
and uh and if we have appropriate care
within our walls then we would get
patients into the appropriate care
within our walls but there are certainly
times that patients might those
treatments may not have worked they may
be failing the patient and at that time
we want to look more broadly for what
other people are doing treatment options
that they would have but that might
require
sharing information with a system that
can help us find those trials right
there's no person that can carry every
clinical trial in their brain and what
the requirements are so we need a system
to help us
find the trials for the patient and at
times that could include genetic
information such as a woman's broccoli
broca two status and things like that
so we want to be able to use those
systems to find the trials that that
might work for a patient that's failing
conventional therapy so that system
isn't a lab per se they're not receiving
genetic material they're just receiving
data results from that in order to help
them get there
the um you know we would generally if we
were talking about non-genetic
information we would consider that type
of system to be within the general
consent for treatment where we use
clinical Partners to help us you know
Outsource that knowledge of where we can
find the treatment and we just want to
use the that discrete genetic data in
the same way where within our general
consent we're finding options for the
patient because we just you know we
don't have all of that technology within
our own building we of course need
Partners to help us to to do that to
find trials and treatment options for
patients so we're just trying to include
those people in order to help find out
treatment options for the patients if
that's helpful in the house of some kind
or
uh it's not well I mean for clinical
trials in particular yeah so they're
filed with the NIH
um they're filed with the NIH and all of
their particulars and then we have a
partner that that essentially goes
through all of those like catalogs all
of those keeps all of their requirements
for us that interfaces with our patients
so that we can see where our patients
would fit into all of the trials that
have been filed with the NIH
um what type of entity is that is it
that contract research organization or
another type of entity
I I guess ultimately they're a software
company I'm not trying to be silly in
saying that but they
um uh just like epic is our EMR as a
software company that helps us have
medical records uh this is a company
that that writes matching programs where
they take our data and that data and
they they find the overlap and then they
would inform the clinician
your patient who's coming in on Tuesday
to be seen has these other options
available to them and then the clinician
can present that to the patient so they
help us find that ahead of time so that
we can approach the patient about what's
available so is that essentially taking
that information that's available on
clinicaltrials.gov putting it into a
more usable and more searchable format
so that you can match the patient with
the enrollment criteria of different
clinical trials yes
fantastic
um I have another question is this lack
of access one of the reasons why
clinical research has not been as active
at Dartmouth in more recent years than
it used to be in the past especially in
oncology
particularly around clinical trial
smashing yes this is why we want to
press forward with this is that we have
been limited in our ability to get
patients into clinical trials
um and we are really trying to push that
harder that we have broader options for
the patients that we see that has been a
driver for finding this partner so that
we can find more options for them thank
you and then that'll come to more of a
re-engagement with industry that's
bringing these clinical trials to the
patients of New Hampshire
it is and of course it's everything
that's filed with
clinicaltrials.gov right so there are
industry interests in there that may
have specific drugs but there would also
be trials that are just protocols on
already approved drugs which you know
are academically based in universities
and not necessarily in Industry so
industry would be involved but it would
not be exclusive to Industry and has
this limited some of the research
efforts that Dartmouth itself wanted to
do as a study within the institution
the the lack of access to match this
genetic data
internally or has it just been an issue
that that that's not really relevant so
the the genetic data is not the largest
piece of that right the the largest
piece of it is just the ability to hold
all of that information together needing
a system that holds all that together
and most of the clinical trials data is
not dependent on genetic testing right
most cancers are not related to Bronco
one Bronco two and sort of known tumor
markers like that
and tumor genomics specifically were
excluded in the original statute which
is different tumor genomics being
different than someone's genome and
their DNA
um so so the genetic information is not
the key issue there and a lot of that
work can be done without genetic
information but in some instances it's
necessary to help patients get
to their best care
thank you that helps me a lot
representative Weber
I'm still trying to figure out how to
simplify rather than complicate matters
and
um with that in mind it's it's a nice
that Senator Apprentice has just come in
because I'm looking at her original
filing
which takes the first to the two
existing sentences of Roman 4.
nothing in this section shall be
construed to regulate or to apply to
genetic testing or genetic analysis used
for diagnosis or treatment of a patient
by a Clinical Laboratory that has
received a specimen referral from the
individual patient's treating physician
genetic counselor or another Laboratory
the next sentence which follows on to
that sentence so maybe not splitting it
is a good idea nothing in this section
shall be construed so as to waive the
requirement that the treating physician
obtains specific informed consent in
accordance with the provisions of this
section so there's the specific informed
consent right there
um and the original Bill added this
section shall not prohibit the
disclosure of genetic testing or genetic
analysis to clinical entities
participating
in processes related to clinical care of
the patient and we could either put a
period there or we could then allow the
or clinical research to go forward I
would say if you were putting a period
there and having the research piece
be addressed differently
because I think that if we went back to
the beginning and just had that section
apply to the clinical care of the
patient so we can solve problem one and
make it clear that the patient has the
right to consent to all of this stuff
which I think many people already
believed they had but let's make it
clearer
that might be the way to start and then
have a separate bill that addresses the
research questions that are much
thornier
so that's just
my current thought on it
um thank you I I think that that
clarifies things quite a bit and that
bringing this back to the clinical care
makes it a lot more manageable task in
front of us because we want to make sure
that people have access to these
matching services
and I know I personally would be in
favor of um moving moving that period in
that sentence so that it's after the the
clinical care of the patient to leave
that research separate
representative merchant do you have
something so track along with you
Richard which piece of paper are we
looking at we're not looking a piece of
paper we're looking at the original
statute and
um if I'd be glad to
put this in front of you because I've
actually gotten there
it's I in this is section four
uh
and so it's the two sentences that we've
always had in front of us in non-bold
print and then it was just shall not
prohibit the disclosure of genetic
testing or genetic analysis to clinical
entities
participating in processes related
clinical care of the patient and I am
proposing putting a period after patient
because we've already got specific
informed consent
in the sentence prior
it makes it
I'm with you the only thing I get
nervous about is the word processes
um It's relatively Broad and my concern
is that processes could involve
again HIPAA business associates which is
kind of what I'm concerned about
so if you want to delete that and
somehow take out the word processes
if I understand you correctly would that
be making that line read adding to this
existing law this section shall not
prohibit the disclosure of genetic
testing or genetic analysis to clinical
to entities participating in the
clinical care of the patient yes
that works I would be okay with that I
would be okay with that as well okay and
I think the line above that if I
understand it correctly is on line five
it talks about actually goes into line
six
the
requirement to obtain a specific
informed consent so we're also so the
specific is in there already in the
statute and what we would do
shall not promote the genetic testing or
genetic analysis to we're going to
remove the word clinical from Senator
prentice's original formulation
and then we are going to put the period
after patient is that correct and
correct I'm sorry what do we do with
processes
participating in the clinical care in
clinical care of the patient right
you could you get to go out to OLS I I'm
writing it down and I will confirm with
you that I have the language correctly
um as I'm writing this down is is that
language that would meet your needs as
far as the clinical care goes
I I think so I I
I'm just a doctor I don't write laws so
I
um
uh
I think in the the questions around the
specific consent if they're consenting
to the general treatment if they're
conceited consent to treatment would
allow us to work with our clinical
entities then yes that would accomplish
what I want or what I'm hoping for
fantastic and it already requires the
specific and sort of informed consent in
order to collect that genetic
information for the clinical we already
and that that's already in the statute
so presumably you're already doing that
we already get consents to do treatment
I mean well in reality patients go to a
special Clinic they've made an
appointment like they know full well
that they're going for genetic testing
and then there's specific consent on
that day when they're there it's more
than it's much better than buried in a
list I mean they
to do that testing they have made an
appointment they're seeing someone
especially to do that testing I I think
it's in reality it's quite clear to the
patient what's going on
thank you representative please be clear
about this again by retaining the word
entities versus saying clinical entities
that's relatively Broad and also talking
about entities involved with the
clinical care of the patient which is
ultimately we're trying to get to
hurry up
right I'm looking for those those
partners that we need to use to take
care of the patient that's instead of
the end of the word entities as long as
those entities are somehow contributing
to the clinical care of the patient
so
would you be willing to read back one
more time the last part of the sentence
um yes my first question is uh
representative Merchant did you want to
keep it as clinical entities or entities
participating in the clinical care
energy is fine entities participating in
clinical care the patient okay then I
will read that sentence again this
section shall not prohibit the
disclosure of genetic testing or genetic
analysis to entities participating in
the clinical care of the patient
and you have a
representative Murphy thank you I just
want to be clear on what we're saying
right now in making sure that it's
acceptable for clinical care of the
patient
with those changes in eliminating the
research you know descriptor right now
you're suggestion in my mind another
bill down the road dealing with the
research component of this exactly in
allowing the clinical care to go forward
including the sharing of the genetic
material like bracket genes or whatever
with entities that can help then Place
patients into protocols for the
appropriate treatment
so as these changes are made does that
allow clinicians to do that without the
research component added to that meaning
that as the research goes on
in my mind they are somewhat intertwined
because they do add to the body of
knowledge the up the the most recent
research to make sure that if the
information is withheld from the
research I'm afraid that this may delay
clinical care down the road
am I wrong about that I'm just I'm
worried about leaving out research now
putting a bill forward which means next
year that we have a bill potentially
versus an amendment that includes
research at this point in time
and I think that's because we could
think about researching sort of
broadcasters right there is
um research that actually happened
to a person himself
sorry your microphone is off could you
turn that on in case we are broadcasting
I'm sorry there's research that applies
to the patient themselves and is ongoing
and that has thorough consent
lengthy consent going through all of the
pieces related to that and this clinical
therapist would still let us do that
sort of research right so you're in a
clinical trial you're in a research
protocol someone is watching to see what
happens when you get this treatment so
that is research the second piece which
is getting put off but is still quite
important to me is in the look back
research is in retrospective analysis
where it may not be possible to obtain
consent because it could be decades
since this patient was seen
uh it may not be possible to obtain
consent and there we want to be able to
use in really a minimum necessary or if
necessary a de-identified way to look
back at those records in order to do
retrospective research so for clinical
care or prospective research I think the
first piece would cover what we need for
the retrospective being able to look
back and do analysis
to discover
new things we really need the second
piece to do that
can I could I just start
um
we began with the proposition that there
are two different things going on here
and it's very clear to me
that the research piece
is going to be a much longer process
than we have time for
and so what the committee subcommittee
elected to do was to bifurcate
to pieces and what we're talking about
now is just going ahead with what is
needed for clinical care and then
I understand the urgency of the other
piece but I would rather I I'm in half a
loaf mode right now I would I would
rather make things clearer for clinical
care and then bring another bill
because otherwise our choices are
certainly we can try one more effort at
this but I don't know how long I mean we
theoretically have till the beginning of
June but uh in point of fact the
beginning of June is coming upon us very
quickly and we have to notice everything
so
um you know the other possibilities are
to retain the bill I'm not very
comfortable retaining it I'd like to
have something come out with respect to
possible care so sorry to interrupt
represent it the only thing that I would
say is
um it's the challenge around the
research piece is because of the
distinction between de-identified and
minimum necessary I think we much prefer
that you just adopt de-identified and
then you get three quarters of a loaf as
opposed to the debate with respect to
minimum necessary which I agree is
subject to a longer conversation which
we're happy to engage in but that would
that would be an unfortunate in our our
opinion Omission since I don't think
that piece is that controversial
so if if we were to then add another
sentence I'm working from the words of
uh
17 19 H here
as we also say the following on to the
section that representative Leon drafted
this section shall not however prohibit
and let's take this the however out
shall not prohibit the disclosure of
de-identified data
and we'll cross out or limited minimum
necessary data
so de-identified data within a covered
entity that constitutes genetic testing
or genetic analysis in the context of
IRB approved retrospective clinical
studies
would that work
I understand that representative Kirk is
very unhappy with that but I'm I'm just
asking the people who have been talking
about the conversation all the way
through so far
and we're also out of time just so you
all know that would be a huge step
forward
so if it reads this section shall not
prohibit the disclosure de-identified
data and striking limited minimum
necessary data within a covered entity
that constitutes genetic testing or
genetic analysis in the context of IRB
approved retrospective clinical studies
okay uh so I wrote down very similar to
that I added to the section I had the
section shall not prohibit the
disclosure of genetic testing or genetic
analysis to entities participating in
the clinical care of the patient or
de-identify data in the context of IRB
approved retrospective studies okay does
that does that meet the de-identified
data
she's just shortening it out as a
researcher it's not my
but it's a huge stepfather
it's a great help that you begin
thank you and then we can look to look
to the larger picture about people who
want to contribute more information to
research especially those people with
these with these rare diseases
foreign
thank you um did Senator Apprentice
leave to go to another meeting I was
hoping to I was hoping to see what she
thought about this she was okay I talked
to her before she left um I suppose did
I I specifically asked her about her
return to her original formulation I
thought we'd gotten beyond that but we
clearly haven't although I did not speak
to her about the research part of it it
was only on the consent and she was not
unhappy about the research part of it is
my understanding of what she was
concerned about was that the whole thing
might go south because of the research
part correct
I think Madam chair we could I saw uh
reps of The Honorable Neil Park out
there with his hands waving we may want
to hear from him as well
I I thank you gentlemen very much for
being here we appreciate you being here
thank you thank you for your time and
attention to it I really do appreciate
it absolutely thank you uh The Honorable
Neil Kirk would you like to share your
perspective on this with us
and bearing in mind that we are now over
time for the committee yes and and we
are moving into our executive session
time so thank you very much Madam
chairman I think you've done some very
good work on the clinical part of it and
I don't have any problem with allowing
access to de-identify data because that
doesn't affect an individual's privacy
however
you don't Define de-identified and by
using the IRB in that sentence you in
effect allow them to determine what
de-identified is and their definition of
de-identified is not what you and I
would think
so
if you just use the word de-identified
and don't do anything further but
eliminate the IRB The Mention Of IRB
you've gone one step further to making
it clear to everyone especially since
the record will show that you took out
by our IRB that you're talking about
true de-identification because the IRB
allows in certain cases much more
information that would allow for
identification of individuals and they
justify that by the needs the necessary
needs of research the point is it's
outside the control of this body and I
think this body needs to Define what
they mean by de-identification in my
concept that means that it's not
possible to put a name
no matter what other information you get
from no other from whatever resources
it's not possible to put a name with the
data they don't have that concept if you
like my concept you need to take IRB out
if you put IRB in there then you're
basically solving the research problem
because that's what Dartmouth needs they
want to use the IRB criteria to access
data without consent
um I have a question for you if we add a
definition of the term di identified
data into the um into the the section
one of this bill where it has the
definitions in order to narrow it down
to de-identified data in a way that's
protective of individual privacy as you
would be able to describe for us but
then allowed it only in the context of
IRB approved retrospective studies so
that we do have some other controls on
that because that works competing at
interest that works if you could provide
that language we'd love to be able to
try and get this drafted is that
something that would work for both of
you to have a definition if we agree I
think we're going to need another
subcommittee meeting to look at that I I
think if perhaps The Honorable you know
sort of can circulate that to both Mr
hood and and the committee we can think
about it but I think I think that we're
not going to resolve it now and I do
think we need to have more discussion
before we get to a final we'll have that
in or in your inboxes tomorrow morning
thank you fantastic
yes representative Merchant thank you so
my understanding isn't IRB
is part of the covered entity
so therefore is are we
I hear what you're concerned is I don't
disagree with you what I'm saying though
is by striking the IRB on line 14.
indirectly or as well as directly are we
still including the rrb because it's
part of the covered entity
I I'm sorry but I don't know the answer
to that I think uh they would folks from
Dartmouth might be able to answer that
thank you
um thank you very much um I'm thinking
thank you madam chairman thank you I I
think we will we need to come back for
another subcommittee meeting on this um
that we will speak to and we'll figure
out a time for that
yes we need to have that submitted by
three o'clock today so we will speak to
our availability and get that into the
calendar
and so if that's acceptable at all I
think we've made some good progress
actually now that I am available both
Tuesday and Wednesday next week for your
purposes okay
see you next Tuesday is going to be the
16th yes I am and the 17th we could do
it again before this week
um I am available on the 16th I'm not
available on the 17th okay
um does 10 30 work for both of you
um so we will have another meeting at
the subcommittee at 10 30 uh next
Tuesday the 17th
is our are there any major conflicts
okay fantastic we are the only ones that
count yes very true
okay so that that's when we will be
meeting Tuesday at 10 30 next week
thank you and with that I will close the
subcommittee meeting on Senate Bill 240.
thank you madam chairman
oh sorry the sixth thank you very much
the 16th I apologize
it's Tuesday the 16th I have a field day
on the 17th that I will not miss
thank you
yes
I am not the chairman but I'd expect we
don't start until at least 10 10 because
I know I'm at least uh running upstairs
I thought there was still a lot of holes
anyway
morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs
um before we get into the business of
the day I'd like to ask you to please
join me in the Pledge of Allegiance
pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
thank you everyone
foreign
Bells uh scheduled for executive session
uh today
uh first one is uh Senate Bill 239 I
know that a number of members had
concerns last week we had some
significant amendments offered uh I'm
here and we may even have amendments
today uh so anyway I'll just open up the
floor
um for any uh you know any uh comments
before we
potentially make a motion
representative Nagel you have a 230
um I have some of that one Amendment
okay yeah you you never made me nervous
when you said some amendment I have 412
amendments okay I I we I think we'll
have a formal Problem by the time you
get to the 412th one but sounds like
another bill
anyways
oh yeah
um I would like to make a motion uh uh
to support Amendment
let's see
this is the right one
where is it I'm sorry give me one
breaker yeah
this isn't it though okay
yeah this is it
this isn't the number they sent me
though
um 16 18 H right then at Bill 239 FM
okay please pass that around and then I
want to and y'all moving it's adoption
I'm taking it moving not to pass on that
Amendment yes
and representative Missouri seconds
what I would like to do yes I'm going to
give you more than that too
and then I want to just so that we're
not referring to nebulous things I made
a copy of um
[Applause]
the from the governor's Commission on um
opioid
Alcohol and Other Drugs
um I thought it would be helpful for you
to know what that actually says
because that has a lot to do with harm
reduction
and then I also made a copy of
um the criteria that we use in the
opioid abatement commission for deciding
what we're going to fund for the same
reasons
oh yeah you need more than that don't
you sorry one more one more yeah
I don't need it
okay representative Nagel you've moved
your Amendment representative Missouri
seconded it and uh discussions in order
okay
um so give me one second
I came totally prepared and I'm totally
not prepared
give me one second to pull this up
um so there's two definitions that we've
changed as you know from the very
beginning we're concerned is that there
were two issues that were not well
defined in the original Bill one was the
issue of drug misuse and that was a big
part of the bill
in multiple places to change the
terminology of abuse to misuse and then
also um to add harm reduction which was
also not defined um I've talked with the
sponsor of the bill about this I've met
with a couple folks from HHS to talk
about this and we talked about this and
the opioid abatement Commission
meeting on Monday
um and it's important to note that five
members I believe of the governor's
Commission on Alcohol and Other Drugs
are also in that group so we had a
fairly broad discussion about this um
and we all pretty much agreed on these
definitions so
as a background and I want to tell you
why this is important so um to me and
other people
so about 30 years ago
um when we were planning on changing
opioid policy in this state and trying
to make this a multi-stakeholder process
to minimize the harm that may eventually
result which to some degree did
um we had a meeting in New York City
um with all stakeholders from the DEA
the FDA to doctors to nurses to patient
advocacy groups to everybody we sat down
and chatted about this but one of the
more interesting presentations that was
given
was from a sociologist that actually
studied the whole process of of
addiction and what she did was she
actually went to the streets of New York
and interviewed drug dealers and um that
was kind of to find out like why are you
doing this that kind of stuff and what
she came back to us with was this
interesting group of people called
Street doctors
um what they were doing was totally
illegal but it was actually honorable
what they did
was they
um if you needed a drug or some sort for
your blood pressure for your diabetes
for your anxiety for your psychosis for
your pain they would have it and they
felt that they were doing the community
of service they tended to deal with more
low-income people that had limited
access to the Health Care system and
they insisted that they were doing a
good thing and the reason why this is
important is when you look at the whole
concept of what's going on here these
people are using pharmaceutical agents
illegally for legitimate legitimate
medical purpose
that's kind of where the term misuse as
opposed to abuse came from and that's
why the the distinction is really
important for me personally as we
pointed out earlier if you look at the
latest CDC guides to opioid prescribing
they point out that 70 of the instances
of misuse
um which is a a catch-all category that
includes diversion and abuse
um are due to people it's basically
self-medicating that they're not getting
the treatment that they need they can't
afford the treatment they need and and
they're getting uh substances for other
reasons and to me that's why this
distinction was really important to
change the wording from abuse to misuse
this bill basically empowers the
governor's Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs and the opioid emission
opioid abatement commission to actually
work together to solve problems with
abuse and misuse the bill that we passed
earlier this year HB 66 is is actually
in a sense a harm reduction type bill
that creates a committee to create a um
pilot program and hopefully eventually
State policy to find alternative ways to
manage pain so that people in pain don't
have to go to the streets to get their
medications which is definitely
happening now by changing that language
you actually open up this bill to the
potential of getting opioid abatement
money which is about 310 million dollars
in total so without this language that
doesn't happen so that's why that's
important I'm sorry I have my computer
um
so I'd like to if anybody has questions
on that maybe is a good time to ask now
and then I'd like to go into harm
reduction
um or I can just go right any discussion
on the amendment
any discussion at all right I just want
to commend perhaps of um Nagel because
on line seven
the use of the word substance
which includes of course alcohol as well
so I want to Commitment for using that
word
okay
you know what I'm always happy to take
credit for things I didn't do but um
that that's actually at a much higher
level than me so I will forward that on
to the people it response representative
I should proceed then if we have other
and then the other issue was harm
reduction and and I like to explain why
that's important
um so I don't think it's appropriate to
put the terms harm reduction in a bill
without defining what it means
um I had tinkered with the definition
with a whole bunch of people originally
came up with what I presented last time
um and I as time went on uh and talked
with some of the folks from HHS I became
less happy with with doing that
um so what you're seeing right now in
the bill is actually the the direct
language from the samsa which is the
substance abuse mental health services
Administration they basically oversee
mental health function and substance
abuse for the entire country I've worked
with them in a number of settings
creating um
symposia on other things so I do know
these people fairly well
um the reason why this is important is
number one as I've handed out
um this is already included in the
governor's Commission on Alcohol and
Other Drugs so to pair the two it's
important language that we share
um
um the Senate Bill 32 that we already
passed has this language in it and I
thought again it was important to Define
that
um
um the other thing that I hadn't really
thought about that was pointed out at
our commission meeting on Monday was
that in addition to getting funding
um you know organizations that come
through the governor's Commission in
addition to getting funding from opioid
abatement the state and other things
they also get money from samsa and
um the I can't remember who it was who
said it but she said it's really
important that the language be paired
for that purpose alone so that we're
dealing with the same wording when we
talk about State funding from outside
the state
um
I will also point out that um this Bill
had the unanimous support of both the
opioid abatement commission and the um
Governor's commission and these
definitions did so
I'm done if there's any questions any
other questions discussion yes
representative Murphy thank you and
thank you for taking my question
um I'm just trying to understand because
I feel like I think I saw this bill 16
or this amendment last week 1618
um and then received a subsequent email
but the language in the harm reduction
is identical to that with samsa as you
mentioned this is what I'm confused
about except that it does not include uh
after Health Care Services you know when
you in this one right here it says again
promoting a philosophy of Hope Etc et
cetera at the very end but the email I
got stopped short of that at Healthcare
Services but I'm pretty sure I saw this
1618 last week and we were going to
change that is that a minus you're right
this is wrong and I don't they they gave
me the wrong one
I really apologize for that um
and I didn't I emailed out the right one
to everybody right in the right one or
the one that you sent out to everybody
is exactly identical both in the
description of the word misuse but also
in the harm reduction except for it
didn't include the part of the sentence
that begins with and uh promoting a
philosophy of Hope and I was just trying
to clarify that's all so if you if what
I can read for you this 1702 is the
correct number
okay um and I don't know protocol wise
whatever you want to be saved that you
said you sent it up here you made an
email I emailed it out yesterday uh or
two days ago
1702.
I think the language was emailed up but
not the amendment I'm sorry because this
language this is what I pulled out from
upstairs and I didn't review it
beforehand I really apologize
representative Weber
could perhaps our researcher go and get
the text of the proper Amendment so we
would have it could you help us out with
that
so it was
1702 was the amendment
apparently 1618 was reprinted by mistake
so we don't have the one with the
correction so what we need is 1702.
thank you yeah I'm very sorry about that
I went to Great Lengths to make sure we
had the right one
I know there were concern a
representative of King
thank you Mr chair I don't know if we're
just killing a few moments time while
we're waiting for that I've got a
question that's true absolutely maybe
um maybe Dr Nagel can answer um I was
really intrigued by the street doctors
you were talking about yes um one
question this is an honest question
non-ratorical I don't know the answer to
um and that is I've never understood so
we have this um
um this narrative that people that are
on opiates or Vicodin or oxycodone or
whatever
um for some reason they get taken off of
those drugs from their their legal
doctors and so then all of a sudden
they're turning to like heroin to kill
the pain or something and what I don't
understand is if there's a market for
oxycodone or Vicodin or whatever why
aren't they just buying those things on
the street instead of heroin so can you
just explain that to me I can totally
yeah I mean
you buy what you can get and you buy
what you can afford heroin's cheap I
mean some people do that we've had
patients that were well maintained for
decades on opioids that for basically
because of bureaucratic pressure and
administrative pressure their doctors
took them off or you know I I can't
always judge but I've seen that we had a
patient that we followed through Vermont
that I was actually asked to testify on
behalf of his estate that committed
suicide because of that
um anyways you get what you can get and
oxycontin I'm not a street guy so I
don't know the cost of these things but
heroin is definitely cheaper than
Oxycontin and if you know if you're you
know this one patient got a was taken
off of
um 20 years of methadone sent to a
um
you know a detox center functionally six
day detox and then given nothing and he
shot himself a couple days later so we
that is what we see is that people are
detoxed they're abandoned
inappropriately they're detoxed and
appropriately and they basically are
desperate they're in withdrawal they
need something and so they will take
what they can get and in an Ideal World
yes they would get Oxycontin but we are
also seeing if we've had some wonderful
lectures from the DEA folks that work at
the southern border that know the
cartels very well and we know that
Oxycontin also has fentanyl in it now
the street stuff and you can also the
pills that you get look totally
indistinguishable for what you can get
at the pharmacy so it's a huge public
health problem
um this is why this issue is really
important to me because we're talking
about a public health problem of an
opioid crisis with people
um you know that become addicted and
take it for reasons that would be
considered abuse but were also created a
simultaneous Public Health crisis that
we call the opioid Refugee crisis where
people that have been well maintained
for years or we talked earlier about
people at the end of life that can't get
appropriate management that are turning
to the street to get what they need or
we actually this sounds really morbid
and sick but through my organization we
have a thing called a suicide watch
because the problem is when you die most
people aren't kind enough to give us a
note to explain why they died
um somewhat jokingly very jokingly I
said that we should have passed a state
law that requires people to explain why
they commit suicide before they did it
because that's the only way we're going
to get the data but the reality is if
you die of an opioid overdose that's how
it gets reported it's not clear always
as to whether it was a suicide from
inappropriate pain management or
whatever or like this person shot
himself if he hadn't left us in
incredibly detailed suicide note we
would have never known that was the
reason he killed himself and it would
have gone down as gun violence as
opposed to just desperation
does that answer your question
I'm sorry this can several day
discussions so representative Leon thank
you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Nagel for all of your
work on this both on this bill and in
the larger picture I know a lot of the
intention of this bill is in order to
align what we're doing with what
reimbursement is and I'm curious if you
know what impact there is on
reimbursement codes if we change the
definition from misuse to abuse because
I I have some the copiers were down
there's some information coming down
that actually the CPT codes are based
off abuse so if we were to change the
definition to misuse we may have some
problems accessing
um accessing some of that insurance
coverage as well so I'm curious if you
know if you have any knowledge on that
the loveliest thing about my job is that
I sit in a cubby hole see patients and I
don't have to worry about that stuff so
my answer is no and it's a really good
question the amendment has arrived by
the way I'm
thank you very much for your patience
remember
representative
thank you
um just a thought about
I I like to say intent of having
definitions for those terms and I don't
have much problem with
misuse definition
but again there are harm reduction
definition includes some
very broad
fields of practice and my concern would
be like if we are opening
uh
uh to some
liabilities or expenditures that are not
required
mixture yes representative point of
water yes since we're talking about a
different amendment should we withdraw
that one so we could continue on this
one okay representative could you
withdraw your motion because it
addressed 16-18 I am more than happy to
withdraw that one representative
Missouri
and do you want to make a motion now on
1702 I would like a motion on autopaths
for
um Amendment
2023-1702
h2sb239 can't represented Missouri do
you I'll be a second okay thank you
representative Merchant
any other discussion on this or any
Jewish address representative I promise
I'm sorry representative Weber
just say that the definition is
considerably less broad now that we have
the amendment
thank you
did you want to address representative
palazzo's comment representative Nagel I
think was addressed to you yeah I I mean
we kind of addressed that last time
um it's a frustrating difficult thing in
the social sciences to come up with a
definition that covers every Everything
one of the thoughts that I actually had
was to subdefine this
um and to include basically just what's
in the governor's commission now
um I got
spanking would be a polite way to say
the response I got to that one um so we
we talked at length basically to keep
the grant applications standard to keep
this the process somewhat Nimble for
changes to leave it in this manner so
that's why we kept it this way or
changed it to this
oh the discussion
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman
um part of my question is around the
harm reduction and my understanding is
that part of that is drug checking
um however we saw in the other body our
bill for drug checking was reduced only
to the fentanyl test strips and so I'm
kind of concerned that we may be
abandoning I think one of the most
important Frontline efforts in order for
a more nebulous set of goals and I'm
actually a bit concerned about what the
direction is when the other body is not
supporting the drug checking which on
the street can help prevent these
fentanyl overdoses and I'm not sure how
best to proceed given that conflict I
don't know if you have any insight
okay
this is great I'm suddenly an expert on
something I don't know a huge amount
about
um
I I would probably defer that question
to people on the commissions because I'm
not sure what our abilities are versus
what the Senate says
um I mean that language is in there that
those things can be funded so
um but I would I'm not smart enough to
know that so I would have to defer that
to somebody else
okay representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman
um I guess it's not a question more of a
statement so um I was hoping that out of
this
um search for a good definition of harm
reduction that we would have a list of
what harm reduction is not
um to be included in here because it is
a little less broad but it is still
quite broad
um
so I I don't know if I can support this
amendment it's 310 million dollars and I
think that we need to be very very
specific thank you
representative Nagel I think that's a
very fair question and that was my
original intent to do it that way
um
the problem then becomes it becomes a
very long list and that's kind of why we
chose to not do it that way
that's the best answer I can give you
but it's a very good question
okay any other discussion on this
amendment
are we ready to vote awesome comment
sure go ahead so I've been doing
um patient advocacy for over 30 years on
this issue and I would really like to
thank everybody for listening to me
um and my patients that I represent
um have told me the same thing this has
been wonderful that we've been able to
get an audience and very um kind
compassionate audience thank you
thank you
okay the motion is ought to pass on
Amendment 1702 H to Senate bill 239.
let's click to call the roll
representative Leon no
representative Cushman no
representative Bill King yes
Representative cofo no
representative McLean no
representative Seth King
yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel yeah
Representative peloso no
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
yes representative Palmer yes
representative Taos yes
and representative McDonald yes
15 to 5.
okay
any other amendments to be considered on
this bill
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman um had we adopted any of the
Amendments that we spoke to last week I
believe had we in front of the clerk
so far we have adopted three amendments
the one that we just passed which was
1702 we've also passed uh 1581 H which
all of these start with 2023 by the way
and also 2023 1505.
thank you
okay do I have a motion of
Representative Leon
um thank you um I had actually some
further discussion um I have some of the
billing codes it's just a screenshot but
I was hoping to distribute these around
I hope that's enough Direction
um so I'm gonna pass this around but one
of my big concerns is it has come to my
attention that there are no billing
codes for
um for alcohol misuse or for
psychoactive drug misuse and that the
psychoactive drug misuse abuse was cut
off on the when the screenshot was sent
around if we're looking at accessing
funding sources we need to be very very
careful not to cut off the reimbursement
under insurance coverage because if
we're aligning this with grant money but
then we take it out of alignment with
funding through through people's
insurance coverage that creates a
problem especially because we've looked
at other bills where we're trying to
expand that coverage for uh for
Behavioral Health for mental health
abuse I believe probably Falls separate
from mental health but I don't I
personally don't know exactly where all
those lines fall and I'm very very
concerned that by redefining as misuse
as opposed to abuse we may miss out on
frankly using people's benefits that
they pay for
okay representative Nagel
so the reason for changing the word from
abuse to misuse it's a just to create a
broader category but within that
category our
you know misuse abuse and um diversion
they're all subsets so you can still use
the term abuse when you're applying for
a grant or or whatever and you can still
use the same coding for that
uh representative Palmer
and I guess my question and is if you're
admitting a patient to the hospital and
you're trying to get reimbursement for
that it's up to the physician to pick
the diagnosis and therefore the code
which wouldn't be covered by this bill
so I would think that would be a
separate issue and and not one that
would concern Us in in passing this
another discussion
oh
I thought the pass is amended I'm sorry
it's really to make a motion for auto
pass
as amended bill
Senate Bill Stadium
oh God this was good 1581 1702 1702.
the first two were 15 81. 1505.02.
emotions my thought to pass has been
made and representative web of seconds
representative Leon
um before we call the role I would like
to call a caucus
okay
okay emotions been made and seconded uh
before we call the caucus representative
angle do you want to speak to your
motion sure and then we'll we'll briefly
I'll take a quick break
um
microphone is
so one of the reasons that I ran for the
legislature we all have our own reasons
why we're here and I think you already
know why I ran but one of the things
that was very important to me was beyond
certain commissions and committees that
I can't be on as a public member one of
them was the opioid abatement commission
and um I am now on that and I was
honored to chair the last two sessions
of it which I think we got quite a bit
done and I was very proud of that
um granted that was not due to me it was
due to the hard work of some people that
some of whom I've known for a long
period of time who share one thing in
common they do a lot with very little
um
um I have a friend Bob twillman who I
think has actually testified before this
committee lives in Kansas and he used to
be the head of the Academy of
Integrative pain medicine but he refers
to an issue that we're dealing with in
our society that he refers to as the
three-headed monster which includes um
problems of
mental health problems which affects
about 51.5 million Americans chronic
pain which affects 66 million Americans
substance abuse abuse disorder which
affects about 33 million Americans and
and what he points out is there's a
substantial overlap between all these
issues what those things all have in
common in our culture and our society is
number one is their complex number two
is they're not curable number three the
goal of treatment is management not cure
number four the management is
interdisciplinary integrative number
five and six most importantly is that
there's limited reimbursement and
there's a limited labor source and what
we're finding out increasingly is the
labor force is increasingly burned out
and they're having more and more trouble
retaining people to do these important
jobs every election cycle that I've seen
for years we stress that we need to do
something about drug abuse mental health
problems and of course chronic pain
always gets left out but on the those
two issues
um
We've ran this bill by the folks in the
governor's commission and by the opioid
um Bateman commission and they both feel
that this bill is extremely important
for what they do
um and it's very important for the
people that do great work we we get
testimony on a regular basis from groups
in the in our in our um community that
do amazing things with very little
um and and they're looking at us as an
opportunity to number one improve their
labor for us number two serve the people
that they seek to serve um and I think
that that's really important to me
um so I think that this bill is our
opportunity to do what we've promised to
do for them
um this is not a simple bill it's very
complicated there's you know my first
read of it was misuse and a harm
reduction but it's much more complicated
that and I do accept understand that but
after going through it in detail I think
that it has a lot of value
um as is and as amended
thank you all right representative Leon
has asked that we we have a brief caucus
so I'm going to ask uh let me be in
recess for 15 minutes and then we'll be
back
I'm all right and assuming that those
who are caucusing are leaving because
there are more people who are not yeah
we're not gonna okay we won't do that to
you
we don't want to do that to any of you
so yeah we'll we'll uh we'll those of us
who are caucus and we'll be leaving the
room
is that
you know one of them
what I do I mean it's it's not Fox three
or four session today
wants to address that
um
I'm withdrawing my
um motion to Auto pass
is amended on those three amendments and
the overall Bill 202 3 17
uh sixth Senate Bill 639
um with Amendment 1702 1581 and 1505. he
said he said what 639 you mean 239 or
239 okay I'm sorry I'm not five seconds
that's right yeah but I would love to
hear one representative Nagel was
withdrawing the forms okay
representative Nagel
um one of the big concerns that we've
had through this entire process was the
um harm reduction language
the alternative motion is going to be
retain it put together a committee or
subgroup to talk about harm reduction
and then bring it back with language
that's
that's not a politician I'm not a
politician I'm not a politician about
that would be more amenable to everybody
by part that would have more bipartisan
support
I'd like to have a vote on that to pass
first
thank you Mr chairman I support the
intention of this bill but I think that
it still needs more work in order to
actually make sure that the money is
going towards those people that we see
the most need in order to serve those
with chronic pain those who have been
kicked off of their doctor's
prescriptions I don't want to kill this
bill I want to improve this bill so that
we can stand together and support this
with the entire house I'm not out here
to kill good programs I'm out here to
make the programs better and make them
be something that we all can be excited
and proud of passing that is why I would
rather see this bill retained so that we
can make it address these challenges and
direct that money more specifically to
those areas that are often missed in
Grants and those that are overlooked in
turn in favor of those areas that are a
little bit easier to request in a little
bit easier to fund because it's a
cleaner and straightforward profit more
straightforward process even if it's not
the one that gets the best value for the
dollar interfacing people with those who
need the most services
representative Weber
I think Mr chairman before
um
before I assert the right to go forward
I would like to have a democratic caucus
sure absolutely
generally I think
I think everyone's back now
okay so the motion on the floor is ought
to pass is amended on uh Senate bill
239.
and I since we're ready to proceed
representative King yes thank you Mr
chair
um I would just like to say a few things
I'd like to thank
um representative Nagel for all the hard
work he's put into this because
um I do think it's a very important
issue what what this bill is trying to
do and um the Lord knows it needs to get
done and I have serious problems with
the main Bill itself and I did vote for
your most recent Amendment because I do
think it takes a poor Bill and makes it
better but even though I did vote for it
I still have some qualms for example it
does it does Define misuse as a sub
using a substance that's not consistent
with legal guidelines and one of the
problems I have with that is let's just
say
um somebody has
um every once in a blue moon really bad
back pain and they know that a half a
Vicodin could fix that they don't
necessarily have a prescription but by
that definition that's drug misuse and
to me that's just drug use and that's
fine and I as as a Libertarian I don't
believe that we need to get a permission
slip from a doctor in order to
self-medicate and
um also I was one of the few in the
house that voted this term to repeal the
the controlled substance act so nobody's
going to pin me as a drug Warrior and I
do believe that people have a right to
self-medicate and I don't like the War
on Drugs but the problem is I also don't
like subsidizing the alt I don't like
going in the opposite opposite extreme
so on one hand we criminalize drugs and
we try and ruin people's lives for what
I would consider simple use of
medication and we're starting to finally
thank God realize the the Folly in that
but unfortunately we're running to the
opposite extreme which is subsidizing
bad behavior and we we're not just this
this legislation isn't just a shot in
the dark it's not like we're we're um
Trailblazers in this we've got a lot of
other cities and states around the
country who have been doing the exact
same things that are in the main Bill
and they have had disastrous results I
cannot with in good conscience support
that so I again I want to appreciate
representative Nagel's hard work on this
is very important I think he made a bad
Bill a little better but there's just
too many things in the bill itself that
are just they're just terrible they're
just terrible so it has to be worked on
one way or the other and that's why I'm
going to be voting against this thank
you a representative uh Leon thank you
Mr chairman
um I think that overall addressing the
harms of drug use and being able to move
away from misuse
um is absolutely important I think that
having a scheme where it requires these
substances to be illegal in order to
provide these Services as a problem I
think that we need to look at this
comprehensively including looking at the
legalization aspect because that reduces
some of those other risks and
stigmatization that's part of this I I
do think that we could get to something
that is a much better process that could
get everybody's support I I don't think
that this is the one that does it so I
will not be voting in support of this I
do believe that if if this moves forward
we need to look at that whole more
comprehensive one and bring back that
the Senate Bill sorry house bill I
believe it was 287 that would actually
allow them to protect conduct drug
checking because right now as the the
Senate is taking a position that they
can't actually do drug checking because
that would be drug paraphernalia and I
think that that would be a critical
aspect in order to add back to this
assuming it makes it to the floor
so I'll be against it but hopefully we
can see a better version emerge in the
coming week representative Weber
microphone I've been informed that
according to the clerk because I am now
hanging out here in the air uh who's my
second I am now the moving party and the
question would be if anybody else would
care to Second the ought to pass motion
okay uh you may take your pick
representative matter of him we don't
hear from you that often so okay
okay
so to clarify what the clerk is saying
the moving party would be what I am now
the moving party and representative
Nutter upon this is the second okay
and thank you for clarifying that
okay other discussion on the motion
in the motion representative Cushman
just briefly I just want to reiterate
um that I I'm this is not
the my desire to retain this bill
is
based on wanting to fix what's wrong
with it I want to see this money go to
help the people that it needs to help
and I want to see it go to them in a way
that um you know we have enough
direction for how it's going to be used
and I think that broadness is just
what's leaving me out and I think it can
be fixed fairly easily if we all come
together and work on it thank you thank
you
of the discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to call
the wall one one final time the motion
is ought to pass is amended on Senate
bill 239.
representative Leon no
representative Cushman no
representative Bill King no
representative kofo
no
representative McLean no
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri no
representative Nagel
Representative peloso no
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative fredis yes
representative Cannon yes
representative Nutter Upham yeah
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant
yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer
yes representative yes and
representative McDonald no
10 to 10. okay
so that will go to the
you have to do
okay
representative Leia
um thank you Mr chairman I move that we
retain Senate Bill 239
okay reserve a second
representative Missouri seconds would
you like to speak to your motion uh yes
thank you Mr chairman um I think it's
very clear that our position is that we
want to make this a bill that we can all
enthusiastically support this is not an
effort to kill the bill or to delay it
but to make sure that the funds are most
directed to those people that are most
in need so I hope that you'll support
the retained motion so that we can
actually make this a much stronger Bill
thank you now the discussion
representative Weber
I'm going to vote against the retained
motion because uh this bill has been
worked on extensively by many many
people the harm is here now the need for
reduction is here now and it is my
opinion that we need to pass this bill
now and get it in place and if there are
things that need to be changed we can
change them going forward but right now
is when we need to act and if we retain
the bill there will be no action on our
part until January after which the bill
will go to the Senate if it passes and
there's no guarantee of Passage and it
will be worked on by the Senate under
the normal calendar so it won't come out
until June of 2024 and I think that's
too long to wait
yes thank you Mr chairman so I I have to
say I I strongly oppose the bill as
currently amended
and and I I oppose it because I think
that the definition of harm reduction is
is still far too broad
I think that we have an opportunity
either to
bring this to the floor without
recommendation
is what I predict might happen here
in which case I think it it has a
potential to be defeated on the house
floor
I believe that if we retain and if it's
defeated
you know we're looking at 20 25 before
we're
able to to address it again
I guess I
I think the the other alternative is
that we come up with something that
potentially all of us can agree on and
even get on consent I don't know but I
think that that we could potentially end
up with something that that we have
pretty broad consensus on
so
um you know I'm in in this case not
willing to support something and and
sort of say we'll fix it later I think
the dangers are too too great there so I
will be voting to retain and I I really
want to urge you that if you care about
this bill I think that there are reasons
to retain it
of the discussion representative King
thank you Mr chair I too will be voting
to retain this bill
um I don't believe in rushed legislation
that is dangerous and also
um we're talking about definitions here
that are going to radically change
basically how we the government view uh
substance use abuse addiction
um and and it could have radical change
for decades to come and yes technically
things can be changed but once the
wheels get moving the inertia can be
extremely difficult to stop or change
course so I think that it behooves us to
slow down get bipartisan support on
something and not not just Ram through
it because I I agree there is serious
problems in this country with substance
addiction abuse misuse whatever you want
to call it but and I have simple they
too I'm very sympathetic towards that
but I also know that the government
in its attempts to remedy a situation
can sometimes make problems worse and
that's my fear with this bill and I
think that we need all hands on deck to
really clean it up thank you thank you
another discussion
so you know all the discussion okay I'll
ask the clerk to call a roll motion is
to retain Senate bill 239.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative Koval yes representative
McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel
represent pelosa yes
representative Weber no
representative McKay no
Representative fredis no
representative Cannon no
representative Nutter Upham no
representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no Representative
tayas no and representative McDonald yes
10 to 10.
okay
so representative Weber was our
parliamentarian so to speak that means a
recommendation I'm going to ask our
researcher just to check with us
um you know retention has failed and not
to passes failed do we also have to vote
itl because I don't think anybody here
really wants itl it was the other two
options that were
I understand that so we have to vote
down itl as well well in that case I
will move itl and urge the body to vote
no okay is there a second
representative Cannon seconds any
discussion representative Weber do you
want to speak to your motion I just want
to make it very clear that I am going to
vote no on my own motion that's that's
an unusual situation to find myself in
but I I don't want this to be itl I
don't and we've defeated retain so we've
got to get through this so we can get it
to the house floor okay thank you
representative pushman thank you Mr
chairman uh this is a very difficult
situation to be in because I did want to
I work on this we could we do have the
option of
um drafting a floor Amendment and trying
to get bipartisan support on that but
you know there's that's a a chance and
we don't know for sure that that's going
to work out
um so unfortunately I believe that I am
um compelled by my principles and my
assessment of this bill to vote against
um to vote in favor of itl
Representative king
um what happens if
um what happens if itl motion fails what
do we do then
representative Weber once we vote itl
we've exhausted all of our options and
then it goes to the floor without
recommendation
and people can write whatever you know
the first motion will be ought to pass
right and people can write whatever
reports for and against that they wish
to
okay another discussion
representative okay thank you again Mr
chair
um I'm going to be reluctantly voting
yes on itl
um
I think that potentially some floor
amendments can be made but um
yeah the there there's a lot of work
that needs to be done and unfortunately
the other two options were exhausted but
um My Hope Is that
um something better can come of it thank
you representative
um thank you Mr chairman I will be
leaning very heavily on the word in
expedient right now I believe that we
still do need to work on this um that
means that I will need to vote in favor
and of inexperiod to legislate even
though I do want to see a solution to
this problem
um and I hope that we can find find some
agreement on the floor
of the discussion representative mazura
yes I'm really disappointed that it's
come to this because I was fully in
favor of the retention in hopes of
making this better
um and I don't like the itl motion at
all but I have really no choice
um that we've that it's come to this
this result
um so I'm I don't like this and but I
will have to vote itl because we did not
do the retention
representative profile
I I must admit I am very conflicted
because
I I do believe that
the intention behind this bill is a good
intention
um
I I want I want to vote for a bill
that that achieves the the the ends that
this bill is intended to achieve uh
without the flaws that I see in it
um
so
so I am going to vote against the itl
motion
um
I'm still very very conflicted but I I
yeah I guess I'll I'll be deciding over
the next minute minute and a half but
um
I'm I I'm hesitant to to to let this
die and then not be able to take it up
until 2025.
and that that is my concern I think it
can be fixed
I wish that we had retained it so that
we could fix it
um I'm gonna put my hope in a floor
Amendment and uh see if we can address
it on the house floor representative
Merchant
thank you Mr chair I will also be voting
against the itl I would encourage my
colleagues on the committee to work with
some of the stakeholders over the summer
I think the benefits in The Spill are
exceed the potential downside so to
address the downside that has been
raised here I would encourage us to get
together over the summer with some of
the stakeholders to draft a bill for
next year thank you
of the discussion
seeing none of our last account
can you ask a question sure go ahead
representative Nagle so if we vote to
itl it's gone correct
if we leave it as is it goes to the
floor
so no matter what we do it's going to
the floor right all right so it's going
to get a house vote no matter what we do
all right at this point
sure go ahead representative the only
way it doesn't get a vote on the floor
is if we vote to retain and that that
vote has failed
another discussion uh representative
McLean just a quick question following
up on our representative Merchant's
comment is if this goes to the floor and
it's itl on the floor do we have an
option still to draft for next year do
we have to wait until the next full
legislative Cycles it can't be brought
back up right it can't be brought back
in its current form
um people may choose to take other
approaches to the issue
although the Senate could potentially
bring it back could they and
representative Weber
I the Senate can do whatever the Senate
wants to do that's what I thought right
then it is a Senate Bill representative
land did you have a no okay
other uh representative Nagel I'm sorry
to keep this is really important um so
the bill will go to the house
assuming we don't what no matter what as
amended yes and then if it passes the
house
what's that representative whoever
it will go to the house without
recommendation right so with the
Amendments that we put in there the
people who and I I will again
turn to Ms dyer for
um clarification
um I think it depends on how the report
in favor of ought to pass is written
and I would assume that the
report would be ought to pass with
Amendment with these amendments
and I'm seeing a nodding head so I'm I'm
I'm feeling a little less out on a limit
I want to know what's actually going to
go to the house and and
the amendments are also going to have to
be voted I think I don't know in this
case whether the
drafting office will consolidate those
or whether they will have us vote them
one by one but we'll have to see
but they'll have to be two reports I
would I would imagine one for ikl and
one for
OTP
that would be correct I would imagine so
anyway
um any other discussion
okay seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
call the wall
representative Leon yes
representative Cushman yes
representative Kent Bill King
um
no
representative profile no
representative McLean no
representative Seth King
yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel
representative peloso yes
representative Weber no
represent McKay
representative Freitas no
representative Cannon no
representative Nutter Upham no
representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no
representative Palmer no
Representative no
and representative McDonald no
5-15
is that the motion for itl fails
okay
um so at this point representative
exhausted all options on I believe so so
the motion will be no recommend well
it'll be no recommendation and go to the
house floor in that fashion
representative play on um could I have
who's going to write the ought to pass
as amended report and get those numbers
again for the green sheet please okay
the vote was fifteen five to Fifteen no
um on the Dodge pass as amended was 10
10. we were out
um
because the ought to pass is amended as
the position I believe that um is ought
to pass is amended the position with
which with
um you would like to take up the floor
okay and could I have those numbers oh
would you be writing that report or I
won't be writing that I will unless
somebody else wants to but I would
invite contribution if anybody would
like to but I guess we have to get it to
you by first thing tomorrow morning as
well we need it tomorrow morning or this
afternoon by three
but she'll have to
have to continue
I will I will do my best to get it
that would be fabulous so it was 1581
1505 and 1702.
16 18. yeah they're going not 16.
they're going to consolidate
yes no we can't vote on that one we've
already finished our voting but for the
floor they have to consolidate if we had
passed all of these things we would have
sent this over to OLS and they would
have drafted a new committee Amendment
that would be the majority committee
Amendment if it had passed so they're
just doing that it hasn't passed
okay and we need somebody to do Ito
representative Cushman I'll write that
okay
it must be in favor of Ito okay it must
be must be why so it has to be like
thank you
okay I think that concludes our our
consideration of Senate Bill 239 for
this today
uh
I can't imagine anything we've forgotten
yes representative Cushman thank you I
just have a clarifying question
so and it's for for you
um so it has to be itl we can't do an
opt to pass with a different Amendment
as our recommendation for a Minority
Report
you could I mean we do often have two
ought to pass as amended reports that it
can't be reported out within without an
amendment number
um so we would need to Perhaps Perhaps
uh yes perhaps let's let's speak to
exactly what that'll be um as when we're
done here as to what that position will
be okay thank you um so I guess then is
when we're done if we could just caucus
with the Republicans after we finish our
business
okay anything else on Senate Bill 239
before we move on
saying none okay next up is Senate Bill
240. I know the subcommittee that we
formed
um a meeting or two ago I think it was
two weeks ago did meet this morning
representative Leon representative Weber
and representative Merchant meta in this
room prior to our executive session I'll
defer to representative um Leon on what
happened what transpired
um thank you Mr chairman we met and
discussed the three topics in the bill
clinical care de-identified data and
clinical research and limited minimum
debt necessary data for research the
subcommittee is focusing on the first
two and we'll meet again on Tuesday May
16th at 10 30 a.m to continue our
business and we greatly appreciate the
contributions of um of those who came to
help us in that subcommittee hearing
today so
one of the areas we will be looking to
is to see about potentially defining
what de-identified data is or are sorry
data multiple not singular
um so that that will be one of the areas
that we'll be looking towards
okay representative Weber did you want
to add anything with representative
Merchant did you want to add anything to
that or no I I guess I would just add
that what the approach that we are
taking is starting from the easiest
issues which are uh the patient's
consent to their own treatment and then
working outwards to the more difficult
areas of uh use for research because we
want to be sure that a patient who
consented for their own treatment is is
understanding what might be happening as
well
okay first a question what time is the
um
is the next work session is it 10 a.m or
10 30. 10 30 A.M
okay anything uh else on Senate bill
240.
so that will be continued
um
I'm not available on the 17th I don't
know if we can continue it out past then
or when we would meet that'll be the
only Bill well our deadline is the first
of June I believe right so there's
another there's another Wednesday there
right so I've been thinking we would
skip next week as far as any kind of
executive session for the committee
yeah and that would allow us if we were
getting close
uh next week in the subcommittee and
wanted to have one more meeting either
on the Tuesday of the the following week
uh I think it would be the 23rd
um or the Wednesday the 24th we could do
that before the committee met okay so
there will not be an executive session
next week
um there will be a house session as
everyone knows but
okay anything else about uh Senate bill
240.
seeing none moving on
to Senate bill 263. now representative
Leon I believe you have a motion um yes
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to move
ought to pass with Amendment
2023-174h and I will hand that out
could I clarify that she's just moving
on to pass on the amendment not
ought to pass with the amendment because
we haven't adopted the amendment yet is
that right
that's the correct procedure yes thank
you
is there a second to representative
Leon's motion representative Missouri
representative uh Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um if you want to distribute that yeah
if I I'm going to distribute a memo from
the Senate council which is really
related to a different Amendment so I
don't know if we'll ever get to that
other Amendment but it is related to the
question of whether the protection the
taxpayer Protections in terms of the 90
10 ratio are in the Bill as is so I'm
just handing this out for information
for future amendments if it comes up
thank you
so I I will let this be distributed
before I speak over it and give
everybody a moment to take a look before
I give some orienting details
I guess I will give the from outer space
perspective on this this amendment
brings the bill into alignment with what
was passed in House Bill 2 and I will
hold any other conversation as you
review this
foreign
see what people looking up as
should anybody have any comments
questions
were you ready for any discussion on
this amendment
representative
thank you very much
as amended this bill restates the same
language passed in House Bill 2 on a
strong bipartisan vote to extend the
sunset on Medicaid expansion in both the
underlying bill and the amended bill
this will sorry in this amendment sorry
it will reestablish the commission to
evaluate the effectiveness and future of
the New Hampshire granted Advantage
Healthcare program and make all the
changes to the taxes and fees that are
in the existing bill this
by amending this we would have the
entire package that is in the budget on
Medicaid expansion and if we are able to
adopt this
I think that we'll be able to make sure
that we're able to continue these
covered Services we need to pass this
bill now there are people that need our
help today and we can wait to address
the problems that exist with this bill
in the near future if we adopt this
amendment
we discussed a lot of the things that
need to be fixed if this bill is going
if this program is going to continue on
for any long period of time there are a
lot of issues and there are quite a few
that we would need to address if we do
not adopt this amendment
but with this amendment we could place
this bill on consent and affirm that we
all believe that this program should go
on and then this program will continue
it is in the budget it is a house
position and that will continue on with
people with a pay grade greater than my
own but with this we can join together
and agree that yes this program must
continue and we can move out of here
today with a good positive vote
um and so I would I'm asking for your
support of this amendment so that we can
join together and say yes let's keep
providing this necessary services
representative Weber
[Music]
I'm just going to say that house bill 2
being the state budget is a gigantic
document and it contains many many
compromises
and the compromise that many of us who
voted for it made was on Medicaid
expansion
uh we were told we those of us who were
here for the hearing on Senate Bill 263
heard everybody except one person
testify in favor of making the program
permanent
those of us who are in favor of making
the program permanent and who understand
that it is already working and proven
and that extending for two years
really hampers any kind of discussion
about how the program is put out to bid
and how savings are made and all the
rest of that uh simply come to a halt
and uh it's not something we can sustain
on a two-year by two year basis and for
all of the people who came and said they
wanted this extended because of the
changes in their lives and that we from
the business and industry Association
through many many many many many other
organizations
across a broad spectrum of our
constituencies
they ask that it be made permanent and I
would like the chance to devote on it
being made permanent so I'm going to
vote against this amendment
of the discussion representative Leon um
thank you just as a point of order I
hope that the statement about who is
present here isn't anything about the
fact that I had to deal with the death
in the family I watched all of the
hearings and I was attending to a death
in the family
in my apologies and and my sorrow for
your loss thank you
of the discussion
representative McLean
I I think we all you know for the sake
of the 33 people who did testify need to
renew the Medicaid expansion you know
because to not do so would be to
basically cut these people off
um so I totally agree that we need to
renew the problem is in making it
permanent and so when we went through
the orientation I pulled up the the
Medicaid report from February 2nd 2023
and I just kind of looked at those
numbers so when Medicaid expansion came
in in 2024 we had a hundred and thirty
thousand people in the state on Medicaid
extent Medicaid standard Medicaid we
added 40 000 to the rolls for so the
full complement was a hundred and
seventy thousand in the intervening nine
years
the standard Medicaid has grown from a
hundred and thirty thousand to a hundred
and forty thousand that's about uh seven
percent increase now in a perfect one
I'd like to see it go down but I could
understand how it might go up seven
percent
the Medicaid expansion complement on the
other hand has gone from forty thousand
to ninety thousand that is a two hundred
and twenty five percent increase
and when I look at the numbers what's
that just an initial Spike maybe because
people were getting acclimated the
program no that that's been a sustained
rate throughout
so it is my belief that that is
something that is going to continue to
grow and I think it puts us
it puts me questioning the
sustainability of what that's going to
do to to our hospitals I don't know what
all the drivers are for that I gotta be
honest my gut is telling me
um that the exchanges are
underperforming
um but I don't really know what that is
I do have anecdotal you know evidence
from talking to people where many people
for example I know one woman who she
retired
and she's not yet eligible for Medicare
so she says I'm going to go and I'm
going to go on the exchanges well what
happened is because her declared income
is so low the only option that she had
available was to go into Medicaid
expansion so I don't know what all the
underlying causes are but I don't know
that we in this committee truly
understand that but the bottom line is
we heard testimony that what this is
doing is this is making up for the
uncompensated care I really believe at
this point we are replacing
uncompensated care with poorly
compensated care and the poorly
compensated care portion is growing and
I think that really is going to create a
sustainability problem down the road and
we could look at 10 years from now our
small hospitals being in real trouble so
the way I see this renewal this renewal
is going to be a tourniquet it's
something thing that has to stop the
bleeding but we it cannot be the final
fix we have to come back we have to
revisit and we have to understand how
all these pieces go together and I don't
think we do it this time well enough to
say that we are going to do a permanent
reauthorization of Medicaid expansion so
I like this approach uh thank you Mr
chair representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um I will be voting against this
amendment and I just want to give a
little bit of information I think we
could get a lot of information because
we have a lot of people from Department
of Health and Human Services here but I
don't think we really need it
um
a great portion of that expansion of
expanded medicaid is due to the National
Health Emergency which
um
where wherein there was Federal rules
that Medicaid could not expire
so that is
um so the numbers went up by tens of
thousands of people because of a federal
rule that said we could not have people
leave Medicaid that's for standard
Medicaid and expanded Medicaid and I
think
um as you might have heard in the news
that um
the Department of Human Health and Human
Services is doing their best to reach
out to people so people who are still
eligible can maintain their eligibility
and people who are no longer eligible
because they either
got employment or got better employment
who or were laid off and went back to
their jobs will be removed for the
Medicaid rolls and that is happening as
we speak and the expectation is that the
number for Medicaid expansion will go
back down to about 50 000 people and I
think that um
you know the the financial note about
supporting
um
Medicaid expansion was done with in
consideration of the fact that the
number will be much lower so I do think
we I do think we have information about
that and I think we could get into a I'm
sure we could get into a long debate
about this but
um
I don't know that it's necessary so I
will be voting against
um this amendment thank you
representative Wayan um thank you Mr
chairman um I would actually like to
commend the department for their and Mr
Lipman if he's here for their efforts in
order to make sure that we're getting
through this backlog of people
um it was my understanding that we'll be
coming down to 65 000 from the which is
greatly down from the peak and I know
that the plan that we've done in New
Hampshire is better than what a lot of
states are doing so thank you thank you
thank you but that increased from 40 to
65 is Meaningful and that's why it's so
important to continue this program and
not let it get caught in limbo and then
to have time moving forward but I think
I think we've all already said just
about everything that we can say about
this bill
thank you I'm representative Missouri
thank you Mr chair
um I'm coming at this from a freshman
late legislator Viewpoint and that I'm
very hesitant to make any kind of
program permanent because from my
viewpoint
that makes it that withdraws some
accountability and transparency to the
process of it and so I did vote on it
for hb2 because that would in my from
what I saw was in that making something
permanent is not that and I am not in
favor of stopping Medicaid that's not
what this is this is let's Place some
markers on it so that we can keep
looking at it making it better making
sure things are happening that are
supposed to be happening just sending it
into Oblivion forever is not that so
I you know I've I've seen the
exasperated looks around the room but I
see this as opportunity
um not you know the amendments are only
only brought forth to make this better
and so I see us
putting some sort of kind of marker on
this as an opportunity as legislators to
do what we were voted in to do and not
just send something into Forever Without
revisiting it again so I feel really
strongly about that so that's why I am
in favor of this amendment because I
want accountability and people say oh
well don't worry about it it's federal
dollars that will pay for it federal
dollars are our tax dollars and they are
the people who voted for us it's their
tax dollars too and so we owe it to them
to keep this at the Forefront of the
very important thing that we keep paying
attention to on a regular basis not
sending it into Forever Without that so
that's my viewpoint thank you of the
discussion
representative farmer
So speaking of tax dollars uh from the
original testimony commissioner lippman
had said that there would be issues with
a two-year contract
trying to get contracts with the
insurers for two years and that also
might be more expensive and so my
concern would be if you set a two-year
limit are we then going to actually be
spending more money than we need to
on this on this program
of the discussion
so you know the discussion I'll ask the
clerk to call the roll motion is ought
to pass on amendments one seven four two
H to Senate bill 263.
representative Leon yes representative
Cushman yes representative Bill King yes
representative cofo yes
representative McLean yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missouri yes
representative Nagel
representative pelosa yes
representative Weber no
representative McKay no
representative Freitas no
representative Cannon no
Representative no
representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant no
represent Murphy no
representative Palmer no
Representative no and representative
McDonald yes 10 to 10.
okay Amendment fails 10 to 10.
representative Leon did you have another
motion
um
I think we've talked this to death and I
think we probably should go for the next
motion which would be ought to pass
okay you're moving Senate Bill 265 to
pass
would you rather vote that
representative Weber hi
representative Merchant oh no I'd have
another amendment I wanted to introduce
okay thank you
it was Amendment drafted by myself and
representative Cushman
oops
very good
remember yes
the representative of merchant are you
moving out to pass on this amendment yes
Mr chair is there a second we we don't
have enough copies oh sorry
oh
do we have a second on the amendment
I realize we're not quite ready to
discuss it yet but
uh one four eight three h
uh do I have a second representative
pushman are you you want a second or no
okay that's all right
any uh do I not have a segment
and she did she does and she declined
there's a second I need a second
okay representative McLean seconds thank
you representative representative
merchant do you want to speak to your
motion yes thank you
I during the testimony
um and Senator Bradley was here I
brought up the issue about the growing
cost of pharmaceuticals Within
the healthcare system in general
including Medicaid and my recommendation
at that point in time was to be sure we
had a licensed pharmacist on the
commission to help deal with the rising
costs of pharmaceutical cares I did work
with representative Cushman
um she's not willing to Second this uh
maybe we could go back and come up with
another amendment to strike the Joshua
Violet Center that was added as a
courtesy to representative from Cushman
um but obviously just wanted to support
the amendment we could withdraw that as
well and I could go back upstairs and
quickly get another amendment to strike
that we also wanted to hear which
Senator Bradley agreed to was receiving
public input from the issues discussed
by the commission if that's something
also that
president of Cushman wanted to add are
you glad to go upstairs quickly and get
this redrafted so all we have to do is
add the licensed pharmacist to the to
the bill
so people want to just narrow it down to
that I'll be more than glad to go
upstairs quickly and get that redirected
now the discussion by representative
Cushman thank you and I apologize
representative Merchant it's no slight
against you but after finding out more
about RSA 14 and the the law that
dictates that these commissions are
supposed to be a majority legislators
um I I am not comfortable
I'm not comfortable with the commission
as it is
um and I don't think that adding these
two positions is going to have much
meaningful impact
um I think that it should be legislators
image already the way that the statute
has it now and that we shouldn't be
accept exempting it from that and
especially the way that this particular
commission has evolved since it started
where initially it was
only legislators who had a voting power
and then gradually over time it has
become that a lot of the
other people on the commission have
voting power and I just can't support it
at all so
Mr chair I guess the question to the
chair and to the committee
how quick I can get this to be redrafted
so all we have is number 16. we delete
17 and number nine
other comments on this uh the
representative Merchant's Point
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman if we're going to start working
on fixing the program I literally have a
file box sitting right here at my knees
of all of the ways to fix this I would
just like to find a way for us to say
that we have a position and to move
forward so we don't have to spend our
time now and then next week trying to
refine this program I would rather much
okay so this this amendment will not be
considered
um
do I have another motion on the on
Senate bill 263.
anybody wish to make a motion
representative Shapiro I I move or to
pass on Senate bill Tuesday Senate Bill
263. okay representative Weber seconds
a representative Shapiro do you want to
speak to your motion or
I will just say briefly that um
we have given a lot of attention to this
including in a public hearing we've had
a lot of expert testimony we clearly
have a lot of disagreement both about
the details of the program and I think
about the philosophy of the program so I
I don't think um
as evident by the discussion
today last week the week before I don't
think we're gonna necessarily reach
consensus but I think that this is an
important program it's a program where
there's been an outpouring of support
from our constituents and I think we
should pass it permanently so I hope you
will vote
ought to pass
any other discussion
seeing no other discussion okay I'll ask
that the clear call the wall
representative Leon no
representative Cushman no
representative Bill King no
Representative kofo no
represent McLean nope
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri no
representative Nagel
Representative pelosa no
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes
representative Freitas
yes
representative Cannon yes
representative
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
Tellez yes and representative McDonald
no
10 to 10.
you know we do we have to consider you
have to do the opportunity
representative Leon
um I'll move in expedient to legislate
foreign
seconds
okay do you want to speak to your motion
yes please
um in the interest of thoroughness and
completeness I have moved and expedient
to let us legislate but my position on
this
um in the end will end up being ought to
pass as amended by um the the one that
matches House Bill too so I'm going to
be voting against my motion and I hope
that everybody else does as well because
we all agree that we can't withdraw
these services to people right now and
we all agree that this program should be
continued should continue the question
is how it continues and with two years
we buy time to be able to deal with
those issues as opposed to dealing with
them next week
okay now the discussion
so you know representative McLean is
there any value in retaining it as a
backstop or
is there any interest
okay any other discussion
seeing none I'll ask the clerk to
Colorado motion is ought to pass on
Senate bill I mean excuse me the motion
is itl outside of Bill 263.
representative Leon no
representative Cushman
no
representative Bill King no
representative
Cobalt no
representative McLean no
representative Seth King no
representative Missouri no
representative Nagel
representative peloso
yes
representative Weber no
representative McKay no
representative Freitas no
representative Cannon no
representative Nutter Upham
representative Shapiro no
representative Merchant no
representative Murphy no representative
Palmer no
Representative no
representative McDonald no and one to
19.
okay
motion from itl fails
okay so this point we're going without
recommendation
to the house floor we need somebody to
write the
report on each right I'll write the
report on ought to pass is amended by a
1742.
okay
1742 not 1483. oh actually right sorry
never mind
okay we need another company we need
another committee report right I'll
write the report
oh
people have to look I'm doing the other
one okay representative Shapiro you're
doing the ought to pass okay
yes
and we need
we need we need one for ichio
okay because because it's it's perfectly
okay to have
reports of ought to pass with two
different amendments that happens
perfect not often but with some
consistency
okay so any other discussion on on this
uh on Senate bill 263.
okay and uh again that was an early Bill
also uh so that is going to have to um
you know we need those reports
unfortunately I guess first thing in the
morning and what Ms Dyer said okay
so thank you all uh the only other item
of business to bring before us again
we're not meeting next week uh the house
is but the subcommittee needs more time
to work on 240. Senate Bill 240. uh we
do have 12 retained bills right now I I
am looking for people who and
representative Cushman thank you for
getting back to me representative Canon
thank you for getting back to me
all right thank you so yeah please give
me your feedback as to which uh one of
the retained bills you'd like to help on
if if any uh okay if we need to address
those you know by I think November 18th
it's my memory serves and they'll
obviously ultimately be considered by
the Full House in January but
it would be great for us to get started
on on them in June so that we can get a
head start exactly and and how's
leaderships encourage that too so to
start working on in June if we can so
representative Missouri I have a point
of clarity
um just for myself as a freshman
legislator how this works is to us does
a committee or subcommittee get plate
formed over these retention bills
these retained Wells and again we've
debated that representative Weber I I
know it's it's probably easier to not do
a formal subcommittee is that
we've debated this a lot and people do
them in many different ways we've I I
have sat on committees where the whole
committee sat and dealt with every
single retained Bill and and bills get
retained for all kinds of different
reasons some of them are just to wait
and see if something's going to happen
and if it does you're good others are
really naughty things that we've
retained that need a lot of work
my preference is to refer them to an
official subcommittee which then notices
their hearings because we're not under
the same kind of time pressures we know
we've got till November my preference
would be for an official subcommittee to
be made named by the chair and those
subcommittees maybe not on every Bill
some of them might be simpler but the
the weightier ones and and have those
done uh with the official proceedings
and 91a in place so that the people who
are
interested in that subject have notice
and an ability to come and and either
watch our subcommittees proceed or
participate in them at the pleasure of
the subcommittee we could also just have
people as we did during covid get
together in little uh groups smaller
than a quorum of the committee and work
on them but I think that that's the
least effective way and it's certainly
the least transparent way
so I I prefer to do something that was
formalized so that the members of the
public were interested can come and if
then if they're aggrieved at the end at
least we can say we made an effort to
include everybody
representative so uh apologies uh also
further clarification so would that be
one committee or the Committees for each
one
um it would take more than one
subcommittee definitely so generally
speaking there would be one for each
subject right and and sometimes when
there are when there is one or more
bills on the same broad subject matter
the chair might uh
Clump the ones that are all dealing with
the same thing if we'd retained for
example all three of the systems of care
bills we could you know it would have
made sense to Clump all of those
together but we didn't retain all three
of them so we only have one
my thought might be before I recognize
representative Leon is seeing who's
interested in what subject matters and
then see how they'd you know get some
input from them as to how they'd like to
proceed
if that makes sense representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman I actually
received a scheduling notice for another
committee about the retained bills and
so if we discuss all of the we we try
and figure out our path forward with
who's interested we may be able to
discuss that and then speak to those
subcommittees publicly when we do come
back for Senate Bill 240 and then to
sort of assign those subcommittees and
whatnot and figure out our plans forward
for at least those which we know so that
may be one path that makes more use of
coming back for what will be a short
executive session once we finally
understand uh Senate Bill 240 sure and
then by that time more people have had a
chance to think about what areas they
want to work on representative uh
wherever and I would just caution people
to check with Ms Dyer about what we can
and can't discuss at that meeting unless
it's unless the bills are noticed
specifically
right okay
she and I will discuss that after the
government today
any other business come before the
meeting that is appropriate
well thank you all very much uh I think
we're getting out of here earlier than
most of us anticipated which usually is
a good thing
so thank you and I'll see you uh I'll
see you at the house session next week
we stand adjourned
um and Republicans I wanted to meet with
everybody before you leave please